[Applause]
[Music]
okay here are the questions from the
internet James they say during the
Clinton campaign health care was one
major issue that did not get passed what
do you think of Obamacare being passed
and how do you see it evolving over the
next four years well first of all things
wanted a great legislative political
accomplishments of my lifetime and the
reason is is I something like five
presidents before him tried to do it
they got it done so you got to give him
credit and it was you know in essence
ratified by the public in this election
so I I don't I and I think that is the
the thing in the first term they're
probably most remembered for now the
implementation of it is coming up and
and you know it's gonna be some some
things to deal with and I think that
they're gonna push forward with it but
it was a bill it was so easy why did so
many try before him and not make it and
he got the ball across the finish line
right and it gets more popular as if
that's time as I'm sure you'd agree the
cost issue here is real and pretending
it isn't real is what it is paid for
well it paid for in the pit in the long
run if you look at our demographics and
in what health now is which is
exponentially more and more expensive
than it used to be right you've got to
have some way of restraining those cost
now in the ACA that is written into the
bill they've none of those experiments
have been tested proved right right so
my view is that if you like the Bush tax
cuts give them time to work if they
don't then I'm sorry the premiums are
gonna have to go up we're gonna have to
premium support we're gonna have to have
means testing we're gonna have to what
we can't afford certainly was better
than what we had yes like I was saying
at the beginning we gotta work backwards
from kids don't I just want to point out
something here the private enterprise
delivers healthcare more expensively
than the government does yeah so if you
if you go to that you're gonna increase
health care costs are gonna go up now
you write it we will break the
government if we don't do something else
get cost you're exactly right about that
this takes a shot at it we don't know
how well it's gonna work but we got to
take a shot seeing the irrational
reactions from the right after the loss
of this election is the
a chance for a third party to start
rising in 2016 well we asked that after
every election and really never happens
I mean we all have that thought in our
head but it's just not it it's a
European thing you know because they
have a parliamentary system it works
there to have multiple parties here they
always get absorbed by one of the two
parties and it always winds up hurting
the party that they're more alike I mean
I know that everyone in the on the right
blames the Clinton's presidency on Ross
Perot correct
well yeah which is not accurate but but
yeah I mean whether you're Ralph Nader
or Gary Johnson or even Ron Paul yeah
you sort of marginalized yourself and
then you're brought back into the fold
afterwards and usually with fewer
friends but you might you might have
gained a crowd of sort of young
insurgents who may or may not stay with
you throughout the next four years I
mean Ron Paul certainly has a ton of
fans I don't know that they're going
anywhere but whether he's a realistic
prospect for President of the United
States what Ron Paul did on foreign
policy and changing the at least some of
the parameters of the debate within
Republican Party was vindicated by Mitt
Romney's last debate in which he
basically endorsed Obama's foreign
policy right so the the new Republican
Party has to be and there is no
contradiction Obama's for abusing his
foreign policy no illegally without
asking Congress we have boots on the
ground and you governor Bush look like a
winner clintus do not torture people
I'm sorry that this war criminal
administration that torture if you can
can you can trade in two countries on
the basis in one case of absolutely
flawed evidence compared going into Iraq
where we sent the entire American army
within Libya there were no Gondo where
we have a hundred advisers you can't
really compare your Iraq award that
killed four thousand American
underpinning Bush's foreign policy let
me tell you that your bubble
if you think the rockwool is a good idea
Eisenhower what Congress gave Bush you
know was the the right to strap on the
guns it didn't give him the right to go
in there with guns blazing it was a
little different yeah and so make a
decision to you evade and plus they said
when we found out the premise and they
knew that they didn't have weapons prior
to the time of invasion and that they
took reports that came out that they
didn't have them when the Washington
Post all they had to do was read the
paper and they thought this thing was
gonna work and they messed the concept
Iraq was a war the Constitution says
only Congress can declare what they did
not declare war in Iraq if so that's not
really quite a Republican was
implementing a drone war that killed
hundreds of innocent children children
you would be calling we were impeachment
[Applause]
pushing Romney and it was no big deal
all right that's a big difference
conservatives are dead dead dead okay
final questions so we can end on it on a
more mellow note Mason do you have a
timeline in mind for winning national
legalization and regulation of marijuana
[Applause]
that's a party so here's the thing you
know a great example I mean Colorado
voters repealed alcohol prohibition
exactly 80 years ago they did it prior
to the federal government and a lot of
states did so as well and that
ultimately you know states opting out
saying you know if you don't want to
waste your time and resources you want
to leave it to us we shouldn't have to
waste our time and resources and as
States start to do that this type of
discussion these this election has
inspired this type of national
discussion and and kudos do you bill for
for talking about publicly I hope I hope
that more national aids national media
was a labor of love
Andrew Andrew as well national media
figures need to be talking about this
issue and they are now as a result of
this lastly we need to stop talking
about it as if it's funny I am so tired
I mean the the when when Barack Obama
was asked come on it's a little funny
yeah everything's a little funny I mean
they're the right to save your own life
is not that funny oh okay um and the
right with your own body as you please
is not a subject of humor and I think
that when Barack Obama I'd like to keep
working in
I mean if you look at everything that we
talked about it could all you could say
that everything is kind of serious but
you have to look at things in a humorous
light this particular topic is made fun
of more than others
people start giggling about the munchies
and and all the rest all of which is
great but look at the same time it's a
serious issue if he was as hard on the
wall poverty as he is on the wall drugs
be going a lot better that's the other
aspect of that essentially a war against
black men in cities are in horribly
racist way all right
what's everybody whoa thank you Real
Time with Bill Maher Friday night at
10:00 a spill at his guest to a
questions right after the show at
hbo.com